i don't think i'm going to sleep at all
for the next 90 days because i'm going
to be walking around thinking what do i
have to do today to keep her happy
[Music]
90 day fiance season 2 star jason hitch
has died from complications from covet
19. he was 45 years old
today we are here at rick matthews and
we are going to pitch our snack mail
order business on wednesday jason's
sister shannon confirmed the news to tmz
telling the outlet he died inside the
icu of a hospital in florida on tuesday
with his family by his side
she notes that jason was not vaccinated
into her knowledge he didn't have any
pre-existing medical conditions though
he might have died from other factors
too in a statement to et the network
that airs 90 day fiance tlc shared quote
we are saddened to hear about the
passing of jason hitch and send our
sincere condolences to his family and
friends at this time
oh look they're selling lemonade
they need to work on a few things their
umbrella's not big enough
they're just kids i know honey but i
could help them
what do you want to do buy them a bigger
umbrella
90 day fiance followed jason's journey
with casia tavirez who moved from brazil
to florida to be with the united states
army veteran the pair who had a 15-year
age difference got married in 2014 but
they split in 2017 and were officially
divorced in 2018. once news broke of
jason's death casia shared her thoughts
on instagram
writing quote it's always sad when
someone you spent part of your life with
stops breathing
i guess one could never be prepared for
that i wasn't today when i started
receiving messages i thought it was a
joke i'm shocked my condolences to his
family and friends rest in peace jason
[Music]
you